les images en direct de joe biden qui
s'approche qui fait un pas après l'autre
vers le pouvoir il ay thomas il est à
washington on l'a vu plus tôt avec
jean-françois il est arrivé les images
spectaculaires dans le fait de main car
personne ne veut pas dire que ça sera
pas spectaculaire on a mis deux cent
mille drapeau il y aura des images
chalonnais l'on voit kamala harris et
son mari et joba jean avec jill biden
qui se recueille en mémoire des morts de
la coved et dieu sait qu'il y en a eus
aux états unis
400 millions aujourd'hui
quand même incroyable josée legault
michel david une chirurgie bonsoir
c'était pas prévu un petit tour de table
quand même on peut pas faire autrement
c'est quand même un changement énorme
couac on a vu monsieur tron michel de
remarquer lui qui a changé comme s'il y
avait eu une opération près vous allez
me dire c'est pot s'insère très bien
mais je rends chez de temps aujourd'hui
il veut peut-être rescapés les derniers
morceaux d'humanité qui lui reste peu
importe mais dans quel état d'esprit
nous et ça il veut amadouer les
sénateurs républicains qui pourraient
encore voter sur un pitch meute et je
pense que c'est ça la raison
donc c'est pas la journée du 6 janvier
il y avait changé de 3,4 fois selon les
3 4 messages qui est de faire alors la
première fois ils les mêmes rentrées la
maison des petits-enfants mais je vous
aime la troisième d'annoncer qu'il
accepte bien alors michel david
joe biden je crois vous avez pu voir
tout à l'heure il était très ému parler
de son facebook et mort en 2015 du
cancer du cerveau weeds et c'est lui qui
aurait dû être la banlieue de damas et
ça fait ces drames font partie de sa vie
mais à côté 13 solonnel est très très
bon aussi à ses passages là malgré tout
le reste tout à fait mais on peut
comprendre que monsieur badin soit ému
il ya eu beaucoup d'émotion la saillie
des madame en 216 beau mais bon son
épouse sa fille mais je pense que
monsieur maiden l'oeil doit aussi
ressentir les normes pour s'abattre sur
ses épaules
à compter de demain n'arrive annoncé
dans une situation qui à peu près
inédite dans l'histoire américaine et je
suis assez d'accord avec avec michel on
peut pas penser à un mouvement paysages
et surtout sur kiki qui soutiennent et
c'est avec ces gens là que monsieur
maiden va devoir composer à la je
comprends que monsieur bail de noël et
comme à 0
des motos à la veille de cette journée
là c'est une amérique fracturé pour la
crevette josé il a mis la barre haut 100
millions de doses dans ces cent premiers
jours
oui mais c'est vraiment une urgence
nationale il ya eu plus de morts les
américains de l'aco vite que pendant
toute la deuxième guerre mondiale donc
c'est je suis il ya même plus de mots et
lorsqu'on lorsqu'on regarde c'est pas
seulement à l'émotion qui frappe
je pense que c'est un être aussi
extrêmement rationnelle mais c'est
quelqu'un qui a énormément d'humanité a
donc c'est pas mal at-il pas de total
des hommes et moi non plus je crois pas
à son épiphanie au président sortant
très bientôt
sortis heureusement et monsieur 30 ne
fait que reculer pour mieux sauter
j'imagine après parce que ses supporters
eux malheureusement ne disparaîtront pas
de mains ouais bon choix qu'ils soient
pas trop nombreux demain en tout cas
puis il ya ces deux de bien sûr bien sûr
il faut faire mais on espère que tout va
bien se passer
oui 70 millions d'américains qui ont
voté pour lui très bien alors revenons
chez nous monsieur legault qui prez jeu
trudeau d'interdire les voyages non
essentiels
on écoute monsieur legault et monsieur
trudeau ensuite une personne décide
d'aller à punta cana ou à cancun dans un
tout inclus avec la situation qu'on vit
au québec risque est de ramener le virus
site se retrouver à engorger nos
hôpitaux
j'avoue que je comprends pas je pense
qu'il est temps d'agir
donc aujourd'hui je demande à monsieur
trudeau gouvernement fédéral d'interdire
rapidement tous les vols internationaux
qui sont non essentiels
mais une chose est certain avec ces
nouvelles mutations les circonstances
pourraient changer très rapidement alors
encore on demande aux canadiens de
rester ici au pays
surtout que deux jours au jour les
ministres continuent d'évaluer les
différents enjeux et on pourrait imposer
de nouvelles mesures sans préavis
dépendamment de la situation je trouve
donc ils ferment pas la porte monsieur
legault qui est plus près c'est un tour
de table josée legault
mais oui mon dira un père de famille qui
dit s est enfin là vous allez arrêter
tout casser dans la maison s'ils n'ont
pas peur je vous dis là il va se fâcher
et la psychologie humaine de base pour
tout le monde incluant nous mêmes ce qui
n'est pas interdit la peut se faire
alors les voyages non-essentiels n'étant
pas interdite monsieur trudeau a beau
implorer on a beau traiter les voyageurs
de tous les noms eh bien s'ils peuvent
le faire donc monsieur legault a raison
il faut interdire les voyages non
essentiels sinon c'est qu'on aura
absolument rien n'appuie des derniers
dix mois est ce que j'ai besoin
d'ajouter la présence de nouveaux
variants qui font que le virus a
beaucoup plus contagieux encore et
cetera et cetera
le monsieur trudeau ya un sérieux
problème parce que l'oeil est pris entre
monsieur legault sur les voyages et on
en reparlera peut-être après mai et john
ford le premier ministre ontarien au sur
les vaccins qui l'a commence à
s'impatienter tirer sérieusement y était
très très dure lui aussi aujourd'hui
avec monsieur trudeau alors le premier
ministre qu'elle a day 2 grandes
responsabilités là la vaccination voir
interdire les voyages non essentiels et
il faut qu'il vaut je l'avais d'un
patrick taillon le conditionnel est
sujette à l'heure il peut le faire
monsieur trudeau où le faut arrêter de
dire oui c'est un droit protégé par
l'inconscient mais aucun droit n'est
absolu oui tout à fait les explications
de ce tailleur était très très clairs et
d'ailleurs on sent quand on écoute
monsieur trudeau qui comprend que ça
serait la chose à faire nous parle des
mutations
il va falloir peut-être réfléchir à d je
pense que bon comme d'habitude mais
il ya quand même deux choses qui font
peut-être existé monsieur trudeau
d'abord il ya la conception disons
philosophique du pays de la charte
laurent toujours hésitant à contourner
la charte du ca clairement ça fait
partie de son adn et d'autre part il ya
toute la question du transporteur a été
déjà compliqué actuellement il est
évident que interdire les vols
internationaux savoir encore la
situation des transporteurs encore plus
difficile donc les réclamations qui vont
faire encore plus lourde et sans
monsieur trudeau je m'imagine dos à dos
ils passaient aussi mais je pense que
l'opinion canadienne est pas mal
derrière monsieur lebon la dalle voyait
un sondage interne et c'était plus fort
au québec l'appui à l'interdiction que
dans l'ouest par exemple mais je passais
de l'ordre de 65 % des canadiens en
général qui je pense va devoir va devoir
s'y rend donc chez sujet vous êtes
d'accord que ça va arriver
peut-être mais je vous le jure c'est pas
un problème de droit conditionnel ce un
problème pratique vous fermez vos
frontière avec le mexique
parfait le mexique va suspendre ses vols
vers le canada lui aussi et là vous avez
5000 ses mails je ne sais pas combien
canadien panier au mexique pour fait
quoi si vous le faites avec plusieurs
pays
on a vu que ce qui est arrivé au
printemps on a fait ça hop c'était dans
l'urgence et chats on est obligé
d'affréter des vols pour aller chercher
du monde un peu partout plein de gens
qui pourront pas gagner et tout ça c'est
ça aussi le problème on est quand on
ferme une frontière de façon unilatérale
notre pays voilà fermer de façon
unilatérale
il ya des gens qui vont se retrouver
poignet pourquoi ne jamais fermer la
frontière avec les états unis parce que
tout trafic à tes deux pays pour un peu
pro alors où sont les traces fait
l'essentiel et oui alors c'est un moment
donné il ya aussi qu'il faut regarder
alors moi j'ai l'impression que l espèce
de danse de monsieur très dur de dire
non il faut vraiment profiter ça
pourrait changer pour carnet le moins
possible de l'autre côté le jour il
faudra le faire
josé vous
réagir non mais ça ne fonctionnera pas
encore une fois on ne peut pas demander
à des citoyens de ne pas faire ce qui
leur a permis de faire et on peut porter
tous les jugements qu'on veut et oui
c'est très troublante d'un manque de
solidarité c'est clair mais c'est légal
c'est permis alors ça va se faire ok on
va voir si les variants jose l1 souligné
c'est des variants qui inquiète je le
vaux le répétait de trois fois pour
monsieur legault entre comme celle c'est
ça a l'air plus simple a faim il dit
même un petit mot là dessus a dit m
s'ils le font pas on va trouver des
façons détournées de le faire nous
chaîne à chaque fois que j'ai cru que
monsieur truc que monsieur le goût de
manque quelque chose à me soutenait il
existe que ça soit fait dans la demi
minute
et puis sinon il trouve que c'est de la
mauvaise foi dans ce cas là moi je pense
qu'il ya vraiment quelque chose de
compliqué afin de vraiment très
compliqué donc tout ce qui pourra faire
c'est à l'aéroport s'assurer que des
voyageurs passent dans la bonne
quarantaine et là ça va demander aussi
pas mal de police ils changeraient pas
pu parce pardon non non c'est bien
évident que monsieur d'amour pour
interdire n'est pas en position de faire
la seule chose qui peut faire comme
comme ça avait été fait en partie au
printemps c'est de renforcer les
contrôles à l'arrivée mais je pense qu
il va pouvoir se substituer au
gouvernement fédéral dans la gestion de
la quarantaine vue de l'esprit
je vais ouvrir tout de suite l'autre
parenthèse josé vous avez parlé des
vaccins pilotes froide on a entendu plus
haut il a imploré joba et donne de nous
envoyer une coupe de 15 pour envoyer un
million de daussoulx plaît il ya une
usine pas très loin ça arrivera pas josé
on imagine mal le nord américains ont
tué premier geste envoyé dans un autre
pays des vaccins ils se feraient lapider
la non monsieur faisait aussi référence
alors autrement se font directement
monsieur trudeau où il a dit moi si
j'étais à sa place
et là je le dire poliment l'huile a été
un petit peu moins mais mettons que je
me mettrai dans la phase de faïza la
journée au téléphone pour qu'il débloque
les doses parce que ce qu'ils trouvent
là dans tout ça en plus du fait que le
canada pour ce qui est de son calendrier
de vaccination ne parle d'une majorité
de canadiens seulement à la fin
septembre ce qui est très très tard mais
que maintenant avec ccc césar et de
livraison temporaire de frazer le canada
ça embête le plus pénalisé que d'autres
pays européens par contre alors pourquoi
et ça personne ne nous donne la réponse
à cette question là et c'est une
question lancinante et pénible parce que
les gens continuent de mourir en ce
moment là de l'aco vite des décès
n'arrête pas un petit mot là dessus au
chan avait une chanson g
monsieur trudeau a répondu aujourd'hui
là dessus précisément que jour et nuit
ils appellent file et j'ai passé avait
entendu le temps y'a pas entendre ce
forum je parlais après michel de michel
david oui oui il y avait d'abord on n'a
pas vu les contrats d'approvisionnement
sas kdh et à ce que des pénalités qui
sont prévues dans le code non livraison
de toute évidence je pas certain en tout
cas disons qu'ils en aient et puis il
faut bien voir que le canada par rapport
à l'europe aux états unis on est en
effet le plus gros client est
généralement le plus group ans avant le
petit ces tests mais c'est soit comme ça
les petits clients espèce de laboratoire
faire un partenariat le ils sont ils
sont en avant tout le monde évidemment
je veux vous entendre un peu la
certification des autres accès restent
un des décrets déjà vendu certifié en
grande bretagne un pays qui a une
réputation impeccable là dessus
peut-être qu'on peut aller un peu plus
rapidement parce qu'il y en a deux jours
qui sont dans le pipeline ça compensera
valérie plan demande une exception pour
les sans abri pour qu'ils soient
exemptés du du
huit clos du couvre-feu pardon on va
écouter madame planter la réponse de
monsieur legault ce que je souhaite
c'est qu'elle joue vraiment le goût
accepte cette exaction laisse des eaux
qui à montréal c'est on parle pas de
dire c'est inhérent on faire de fait
près 3000 personnes
j'espère que cette exemption nous sera
accordée pour ce soit officiel et que ça
se fait dans les bonnes règles de l'art
comme j'aime que les choses se fassent
mais on va voir quelle sera la réponse
du gouvernement en ce sens j'espère ne
pas avoir à aller contre le décret
il faut comprendre que si on mettait
dans les règlements le fait qu un
itinérant peut pas recevoir de
contraventions n'importe qui pour être
limoges tonnes itinérant donc vous avez
pas besoin de me donner une
contravention
je pense les policiers y ont eu du bon
jugement avec les d'itinérants les
cellules sont les continue à travailler
je rappelle la mort de raphaël andréens
une houle de 51 ans dont on a découvert
sa mort dimanche matin et mangent les
s'étaient cachés croit ton spock l'air
quand dans une toilette leur exemption
pas josé mais si difficile j'avoue leur
que c'est difficile de trancher bon les
policiers dans les quartiers connaissent
un peu les gens ils savent qu'ils sont
les études les personnes et ses rentes
et qui ne sont pas mais ce qui s'est
passé c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
révoltant et ça nous amène vraiment à la
forêt parce que ça ce qui s'est passé
c'est un peu l'arbre qui cache la forêt
c'est que déjà à montréal on avait un
gros problèmes d'itinérance mais avec la
pandémie patrice vous le voyez comme moi
tout le monde moi c'est une horreur et
dans le quartier du centre sud ou
particulièrement avec l'hôtel du puits
qui a été converti en refuse à écouter
ce sont les abandonner de l'humanité là
alors il ya quelque chose qui ne peuvent
pas autour de la baie dans le
centre-ville et cetera
donc oui il ya eu un drame quelqu'un
devra répondre de ça il y aura enquête
mais le vrai problème c'est que ces gens
là ont besoin de soins ils ont besoin de
logements et des âmes incomplet et josé
il ya des abris avec en place dupuis ça
se remplit pas ce qu'il veut aller il ya
le royal victoria qu'on voit aussi à
michel david joue presque oui moi
j'attendrais une exaction effet le
décret qui a été émis par le
gouvernement est à l'effet monde
interdit
aux gens d'être hors de résidence ou de
ce qui en tient lieu de 20h à 5h par
définition en itinérance en avril n'a
pas de résidence
ça devrait pas ça puisse impliquer la
nuit et si monsieur legault fait
confiance au bon jugement des policiers
mais des policiers vont être capable je
pense de faire la différence devrait pas
y avoir de problème chez nous c'est la
même chose oui ces politiques afin de
faire la liste des devoirs du 10 heures
de la forêt et ses rêves est capable
d'avoir du discernement pour quelqu'un
qui a une âme et leap qui se pose c'est
pour y dessiner l'avenir dont on va se
quitter là dessus merci beaucoup à vous
trois bonne soirée
à très bientôt alors voir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit